welcome to the second session of
lightning talks on fairness and ai
systems i'm amit sharma senior
researcher at microsoft research in
india and i'll be your host
these talks cover mitigation strategies
for fairness related harms and the
research questions that come up in the
process of working on fairness in ai
systems
we'll start with the topic of fairness
in recommendation systems then present
how checklists can support fairness in
the ai lifecycle
and finally discuss research questions
on the challenges of measuring
computational harms and the trade-offs
in up choosing an appropriate fairness
metric with that please welcome kinjal
basu to kick us off
hello everyone my name is kenjal basu
and i'm currently the tech lead for
responsible ai at linkedin and today i'm
going to talk to you about how we can
achieve fairness via post processing for
web scale recommended systems and this
is a joint work with my co-authors
pritham cyrus helois divya and northday
so i'm going to base my talk on a very
concrete example and that is the
connection recommended systems at
linkedin so if you're unfamiliar with
the product it's basically when a viewer
comes to our platform and he or she gets
to see a set of members that is
recommended to him to connect to
now the way the flow works is that you
can start by sending this person an
invite the invite gets received and once
that is accepted then an edge is formed
and you can start having conversations
on the uh with these two people together
so the major question that we want to
ask here is that what is the fairness
criteria for such a score based ranking
or recommendation system now the major
things that we look at in literature are
basically things like demographic parity
predictive rate parity equality of
opportunity and equalized odds you can
think about these metrics as some things
around independence so let's say we have
a binary response y a prediction score s
of x and a protected attribute c then
all of these metric definitions are
basically some forms of independence of
either the response y or the score x and
we want it to be independent of the
protected attribute c
now in this talk we're going to focus on
just the equality of opportunity and
equalize odds and how we can build in
post-processing systems to cure for
these metrics
so what are the mitigation strategies so
we are actually looking for a
post-processing solution which means
that we are trying to find a function f
that takes the original score s of x and
transforms it to f of s of x
and what that does is that we want to
make sure that that transform score
actually satisfies the fairness criteria
and we want this function f to be
feasible but not just that we also
wanted to optimize on model performance
and because this is a ranking system
position bias plays a very important
role and we do pay careful attention
towards that
so if we want to solve for equality of
opportunity we choose the function f to
be the cumulative distribution function
of the score corresponding to this
particular group
and we are shown in the full paper how
that by just choosing that we can
satisfy the equality of opportunity
moreover this is a monotonic
transformation which means that the
ranking for each group actually remains
unchanged
finally for equalized odds the function
that we choose is basically that it's a
function that tries to make sure that
the transform score is as close as
possible to the original score while
maintaining that the equalized
constraints are actually met
and we have shown in the full paper how
this can be solved as a linear program
so lastly i would briefly talk about
some of the results we first started
with some initial experiments on
simulated data that showed on the right
so we created two different data sets
where the score distributions for the
two groups zero and one are kind of
separate shown in red and green but
after we apply let's say the equality of
opportunity read anchor we see that the
positive scores for y equal to one
actually gets very well balanced but not
the negative but when we apply for the
equalized odds it acts on both the y
equal to 1 and the y equal to 0. so now
let's look at how we actually apply this
on a real world experiment
so on the pymk or connection
recommendation problem we choose the
attribute c to being the infrequent and
frequent members so infrequent members
are those people who come to the
platform less and as a result are kind
of underrepresented in the
recommendation system and frequent
members are those who visit the platform
a lot more and as a result are kind of
over represented so what happens is that
because these frequent members are kind
of over represented they get to see a
lot more invitations coming to them and
that's what makes this overall thing a
rich getting richer kind of an effect
which we kind of want to nullify so we
choose our label as invitation sent and
choose the score as the scores of the
top 100 positions and we launch both the
experiments equality of opportunity and
equalize odds what we see from the
reports is that both the cent as well as
the accepted metrics have improved for
the infrequent member while we kept
neutral for the frequent member which
means that we did a really good job of
actually showing or sending more
notifications or more invitations to the
infrequent member while keeping it
neutral for the frequent member and with
that i want to end because of this short
time if you have any questions just feel
free to reach out to me thank you so
much the full paper link is given as
well thank you
hi i'm michael madeo and i'll be
speaking about our research on
co-designing checklists to support
fairness throughout the ai life cycle
as has been widely reported ai systems
can lead to a variety of fairness
related harms including representational
harms such as demeaning or stereotyping
harms of allocating resources or
opportunities and harms related to
disparities in the quality of service
provided by an ai system
all of which may disproportionately
impact already marginalized groups
in 2018 microsoft took steps towards
addressing these challenges by
announcing six ai principles including
fairness and inclusiveness
and in the larger community many tools
and resources have been developed to
help ai practitioners address fairness
related harms including resources such
as checklists for ethics in ai and data
science
but few of these appear to have been
designed with input from the teams that
are intended to use them
in other fields when checklists have
been introduced without involving
practitioners in their design
they've been misused or even ignored
surgeons initially refused to use
surgical checklists while commercial
airline pilots misused preflight
checklists resulting in catastrophe
address this gap we first investigated
what ai practitioners processes are for
identifying and mitigating fairness
related harms
we then explored what they wanted out of
a checklist for fairness in ai and
finally we co-designed such a checklist
with practitioners to support fairness
throughout the design and development
life cycle
to do this we conducted semi-structured
interviews and co-design workshops with
48 industry practitioners from 12
technology companies in roles such as
data scientist machine learning engineer
designer and product manager among
others
in these workshops participants
suggested checklist items for various
stages of a typical ai lifecycle and
iteratively provided feedback on the
items suggested by others
first we found that industry ai teams
mostly have unstructured approaches to
addressing fairness often driven by
individual advocates
but this individual advocacy may be
difficult given organizations incentives
to ship products on rapid time scales
and
due to the social dynamics of teams and
organizations that may inhibit advocacy
practitioners felt that having a formal
process for fairness could empower team
members to identify potential issues and
help teams negotiate priorities but only
if it fit into their existing workflows
and they felt that these checklists must
be supported by an organizational
culture to drive adoption including
integrating into organizations goals and
priorities
following the co-design workshops we
ended up with a checklist to address
fairness related harms across six phases
of ai development
beginning with envisioning a potential
system and potential fairness-related
harms including asking whether ai was
needed at all
to defining model and data requirements
as well as defining what fairness means
for a particular societal context and
defining criteria for measuring fairness
and fairness related harms
this also includes items for prototyping
and building models
including prompting teams to develop
approaches to
identify and assess fairness related
harms such as measuring performance
disparities with disaggregated
evaluations for instance
as well as prompting teams to consider
certain things before launching and
while monitoring ongoing system
performance after deployment including
developing methods for stakeholder
feedback and considering how performance
may be impacted by the deployment
context
and this checklist is available on
microsoft's responsible ai resource page
and we encourage you to download it and
use it in your work
finally it's worth noting that
participants were concerned that
checklists may lead to rote compliance
given that fairness in ai is deeply
contextual for particular
societal contexts and often contested by
stakeholder groups in those contexts
as such practitioners often wanted to be
given or to develop a general checklist
and then to adapt it to fit their
workflow we're conducting ongoing
research into how teams may customize
such a general checklist
if you're interested in learning more
please read our kai paper on this
research or feel free to reach out thank
you
hi this is alexandroltan the question
forsythe the measurement of possible
computational harms that existing ai
technologies may replicate exacerbate or
even cause is critical to building
responsible technologies
to effectively measure such harms
however we first need to determine what
exactly we should be measuring
that is we need to identify what harms
are possible how severe those arms are
and who is likely to be adversely
impacted by them
having clarity about what we need to
measure will enable more effective
measurements and mitigation strategies
however there is a tendency to start
with the mitigations of a harms without
a clear rationale for how those issues
were identified many of which end up
being poorly articulated poorly
understood and poorly operationalized
notions of what constitutes bias and
fairness or stereotyping
this is in part because as researchers
and practitioners we may fail to
recognize and when we try to anticipate
harms a key challenge is often
overcoming our own failures of
imagination
doing better requires challenging
assumptions about what is measured and
mitigated communicating no limitations
of not only ai technologies but also
harm's measurement and mitigation
strategies and clearly articulating
competing goals and constraints
this can in turn inform the development
of frameworks to better identify
possible adverse impacts
to develop better measurements we can
also turn to measurement practices from
social sciences where a clear
distinction is made between what should
be measured or what is the unobservable
phenomenon of interest and what are the
observable properties related to that
phenomenon that we could use to
operationalize its measurement
but let me use a few examples i'll focus
on open text generation applications
like making textual suggestions to
assist users in replying to emails or in
searching for information
such open-ended generation settings
makes it particularly hard to
effectively identify problematic outputs
this is because many problematic
scenarios are context dependent and
generally elusive
consider these examples of search query
conditions none of them contain
profanity hate speech or reflect sexist
or racist views
what makes them problematic is the
context in which they were presented
for instance contagious is an excellent
suggestion for the flu but not for
cancer
effectively avoiding such cases and
setting clear boundaries around the
space of programmatic suggestions is
difficult due to the long tail nature of
writing tasks and variations in data
quality and how people assess potential
harms
indeed by examining when search query
suggestions might be problematic we
found that contextual factors like who
is seeing the suggestions what user
input a suggestion was generated for as
well as factors surrounding data
availability all contributed to how
problematic a suggestion was meant to be
in this is the case even for
applications where the suggestions are
curated take this example of highly
positive life-affirming candidates for
email reply suggestions it's unlikely
that offensive responses would be
surfaced here
so what could the issue be
as this email vignette shows not all
scenarios call for life-affirming
answers none of these suggestions are
appropriate for such an email
in fact in another study our
participants voiced concerns about
several types of reply suggestions
including dissonant suggestions but also
gender assuming unprofessional cultural
mislatch matches overly positive and
confusing and impolite suggestions
but even if we know what harms are
possible measuring them can also be
challenging
let's look at existing efforts that use
benchmark data sets to quantify
computational harms like stereotyping
such data sets often consist of test
pairs of stereotypical and
anti-stereotypical sentences to probe
language models relative preference for
stereotypes
they do so by counting which sentence is
more likely for each test pair obtaining
a perfect score when a model prefers
stereotypes 50 of the time
this perhaps is intuitive
so what is the issue
consider this example in intended to
help test for stereotypes about race and
we're given a context sentence i really
like norwegian someone the test then
checks if for a given language model
this sentence is more likely to be
followed by the sentence marked as
stereotypical the exchange student
became the star of our art shows or by
the anti-stereotypical version where the
student was the star of the football
team
one might quickly notice many issues
related to both what this test is
intending to measure and what is
actually measuring for instance the
norwegian salmon is not
really a historically disadvantaged
group a norwegian is misspelled and it's
also unclear which sentence a good
language model should prefer here
this example is not isolated examining
existing data sets we found cases where
all test pairs were affected by at least
one of these issues that that we
identify
thank you
hi
i am amit deshpande and i am going to
talk about a fine balance
individual fairness and group fairness
the agenda
is
to
tell you about a tale of two fairness
metrics infra marginality and under
ranking
these are new proposals to quantify
individual fairness in classification
and ranking
and we will see interaction between
group fairness and infra marginality and
also group fairness and under ranking
fair classification and ranking has been
a well studied problem
but a lot of focus has been on group
fair classification and ranking
where the notion of fairness is
typically outcome based for example
equal false positive rates or equal
accuracy across groups
it's also common to use representation
based fairness for example demographic
parity or minimum representation
guarantee among the top ranks
is a random classifier fair
a random classifier is group fair
because it gives equal outcomes for two
groups
for most outcome based notions of
fairness
but it is individually unfair because it
treats high risk and low risk
individuals similarly
another question
that got us thinking was is group fair
re-ranking anti-merito credit
so group fair re-ranking or
post-processing for group fair ranking
it maximizes aggregate ranking utility
while maintaining a certain minimum
representation guarantees for groups in
the top ranks or sometimes in the top
prefixes
so one question
that we thought about was how much do
group fare the ranking algorithms under
rank individuals compared to their true
rank
or compared to their peers
the first question
led to this interesting notion called
infra marginality audit or infra
marginality as a definition for
individual fairness and in intra
marginality audit of group fair
classifiers
intra marginality quantifies how much a
classifier deviates from a threshold
classifier on the true risk probability
of individuals
many times in group fairness or in
general in classification
the classifier outputs a score which is
supposed to mimic the true risk
probability of individuals
and infra marginality quantifies how
much a classifier deviates from a
threshold classifier on this
in this sense base classifier that
maximizes accuracy has zero infra
marginality with respect to threshold
half whereas a random classifier has
high infra marginality with respect to
any threshold
we can do infra marginality audit
and what surprisingly we found was that
some state of the art group fair
classifiers can have very high infra
marginality
and
infra marginality audit also gives a way
to choose among multiple group fare
classifiers
a paper on this appeared in forc 20 and
the you can check out the link to the
talk video at the bottom
so this is what we found that when we do
infra marginality audit
we often
can do it even with good estimates of
the true risk probabilities we don't
need the actual true risk probabilities
and under reasonable assumptions the
infra marginality audit still makes
sense and we observe that some state of
the art group where classifiers can have
infra marginality nearly as high as that
of a random classifier
so one must be careful in choosing the
mitigation toolkits in fairness
the other part that i want to talk about
is on the problem of under ranking in
group fair ranking
we define underranking as the worst case
multiplicative displacement of an
individual's two rank in a re-ranking
especially in the case of group for
every ranking
and we
look at the trade-offs between group
fairness and under ranking
we show lower bounds on the optimal
tradeoffs between group fairness and
under ranking and we give an efficient
re-ranking algorithm with simultaneous
underranking and group fairness
guarantees
a paper on this appeared in icml this
year
its joint work with shruti gauranga and
anand lewis from iisc and the talk video
you can check out in the link below
the experiments that we did
there we found out that our algorithm
when compared to other group fair under
ranking state of the art
algorithms
we get the best of both worlds in terms
of under ranking as well as group
fairness and we have a much faster
running time than the baselines
i will end my talk here here are the
links to the papers that you can check
out
thank you